prince harry says meghan markle broke
down in tears before her tell-all
interview with oprah winfrey aired over
the bullying allegations made against
her
there really was not anything off limits
back in march
just days before megan and harry's sit
down with oprah was set to air
news broke that the duchess of sussex
faced a bullying complaint made by one
of her now former close advisors
during her time as a working royal at
kensington palace
something megan has strongly denied the
times newspaper has reported that the
duchess
allegedly bullied two members of her
household staff out of kensington palace
and made the life of the third member of
staff almost unbearable
and those are the allegations they are
strongly refuted
by the duchess of sussex who says she
didn't bully anyone
out of the palace now in the new apple
tv docu-series harry co-created with
oprah winfrey the me you can't see
the duke of sussex recalls the ordeal
and the headlines about his wife
revealing that she actually broke down
crying one night due to the quote
combined effort of the firm and the
media to smear her
i was woken up in the middle of the
night to her crying in her pillow
because she doesn't want to wake me up
because i'm already carrying too much
that's
heartbreaking i held her we talked she
cried and she cried and she
cried i do get the sense that they
really support each other
and they encourage each other e.t sat
down with the docu-series director dawn
porter
and she opened up about harry and
megan's love and support for one another
she has been his number one supporter
and fan and person encouraging him to be
open and honest and
bring his full self to the world i think
that's
that's what couples do when they really
care for each other back in march
megan told oprah that she had suicidal
thoughts while she was pregnant with
their son archie
but harry says she didn't act on those
thoughts for fear of causing her husband
more trauma quote the thing that stopped
her from seeing it through
was how unfair it would be on me after
everything that had happened to my mom
and to now be put in a position of
losing another woman in my life
with a baby inside of her our baby
back in 1997 harry's mom princess diana
died in a tragic car crash when he was
just 12 years old
and while it may be painful to discuss
it all don says the couple is dedicated
to sharing their truth
in order to help others they have
supported each other
in this journey and you know they've
done it
at quite a a personal cost but they
continue to express that it's worth it
that they really really want to help
people
and they're hoping that people seeing
them being so honest will be
we'll encourage people to just talk
about what's happening you know the
first step is just acknowledging
that there's something happening